et retour en images maintenant sur les
moments clés de cette épidémie sur le
territoire français pour en parler nous
sommes avec le docteur général kir zec
médecin urgentiste à l'hôtel dieu ap hp
bonsoir gerald kerzec merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on l'a dit
l'om est vient de déclarer l'urgence
internationale
concrètement le médecin que vous êtes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça change pas
grand chose c'est l' urgence de santé
publique de portée internationale la
dernière fois que ça avait été déclenché
et 7 en juillet 2019 à propos d'une
épidémie d'ebola je mets au défi
quiconque de se rappeler de ce
déclenchement de cette urgence sanitaire
santé publique
donc ça va pas changer grand chose et en
particulier concrètement pour nous sur
les recommandations ou sur la prise en
charge il va pas y avoir de portée
justement de prise en charge et de
mesures concrètes qui vont changer
moi j'ai un peu peur simplement que ça
rajoute un peu de l'huile sur le feu et
que ça rajoute un peu dans une hystérie
un peu collective
on comprend pas bien pourquoi depuis le
début on a l'impression grand manque la
sauce est en train de monter autour de
ce coronavirus alors sous réserve qu'on
nous donne les bons chiffres en chine
mais pour l'instant 160 euros
mort en chine sur un territoire de 1 5
milliard de citoyens
on n'est pas sur quelque chose qui est
dramatique je rappellerai juste qu'en
france chaque année ces 10000 à 15000
morts de la grippe dans l'indifférence
générale
or le coronavirus ce sont des symptômes
d'une grippe peut-être d'une grippe
un peu plus méchante que les autres mais
en tout cas ça a les mêmes modes de
propagation et les mêmes symptômes de la
fièvre de la toux
donc cette urgence de santé publique
clairement elle va affoler h commencé à
regarder déjà sur les réseaux sociaux
les gens s'affolent parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas bien les mots font peur
comme les mots de virus mystérieux
chinois faisait peur aussi et là on a
une combinaison qui est assez
d'étonnantes en termes de communication
tout simplement
alors justement il ya six cas qui ont
été confirmés en france un 6e ce soir il
y avait des risques ce que ça se propage
comment ces personnes sont elles prises
en charge
alors on n'est pas il faut sortir du
fantasme de plaies que savait la
transmission de la peste ou de contagion
le film et brad pitt vous avez un
patient zéro qu'il a infesté toute la
planète et qui va tuer à chaque contact
on est de l'ordre avec le quoran à virus
de quelque chose qui est plus de l'ordre
de la grippe
or la grippe chaque année il ya deux
millions cinq millions 8 millions pour
l'effort année l'effort des épidémies
mais en tout cas la pandémie mondiale de
grippe elle existe donc là il est
probable que ce coureur d'un virus
comme c'est un mode de transmission par
les gouttelettes 1 par la respiration
qui est similaire à celui de la grippe
qu'on ait une dissémination sur la
planète
après la vraie question c'est quelle est
la virulence quelle est la gravité de ce
virus est ce que ce virus
c'est une grippe un peu compliqué et ça
donne des pneumonies mais globalement
c'est pas très grave et ça touche des
gens qui sont fragilisés et c'est
dramatique pour les gens qui sont
fragilisés mais on voit bien que il ya
déjà des maladies qui vont le premier
patient qui est décédé en chine par
exemple avait déjà une tuberculose plus
une une infection du myocarde donc on
voit bien que ça a été un peu la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase mais
le corona virus en lui-même n'a pas été
responsable de ce décès donc soit c'est
un virus qui est pas plus virulent que
ça il va falloir redescendre d'un cran
en termes de communication parce que
nous aux urgences par exemple ou dans
les services hospitaliers s'avère
impossible de mettre tout le monde en
isolant soi il est très virulent et ça
voudrait dire que la chine peut être ne
cache un certain nombre de choses ou que
les chiffres ne sont pas les bons
chiffres et à ce moment là s'il est très
virulent certes c'est moindre contact
avec des gens qui n'ont pas
d'antécédents médicaux
il ya un risque et une gravité ça veut
dire que là effectivement on a raison de
prendre toutes les précautions mais ça
va poser problème parce qu'il faudra
avoir le nombre de services de
réanimation qui permettront d'accueillir
les malades potentiels
on a virus se soigner il
et se soigne pas asser qu'il passe tout
seul mais un peu comme la grippe quand
vous avez la grippe ou le coronavirus on
va vous donner du paracétamol pour faire
baisser la fièvre on va donner
éventuellement des antiviraux pour les
cas les plus graves
et puis surtout c'est surveillé
l'évolution donc là c'est quand vous
avez des symptômes toux fièvre des
symptômes respiratoires et que vous
revenez de chine
ce sont les critères de la région
concernée ou bien que vous avez en
contact avec quelqu'un qui est un cas
diagnostiqué ce qui tient du sixième cas
avec le médecin qui a été en contact
avec un patient qui lui même avait des
symptômes qui ont été confirmés dans un
deuxième temps eh bien il faut mettre en
isolement
et puis il faut surveiller l'évolution
12 l'hospitalisation systématique on
isole et on surveille la situation
évolue bien vous allez sortir de
l'hôpital la situation évolue mal vous
allez aller en réanimation mais on voit
bien que c'est gérable sur 5,6 qu'à 60
cas il était qu'on va dépasser une
centaine de cas par exemple en même
temps ça va devenir compliqué à paris il
ya cette chambre à l'hôpital bichat
cette chambre à la pitié salpêtrière
d'isolement et puis après on va vite
être limité par les moyens de ses
chambres d'isolement c'est la même chose
sur les moyens de
sans ça je souhaiterais vraiment que on
puisse peut-être redescendre la tension
si on a affaire à un virus qui n'est pas
si grave que ça on n'est pas sûrs et
voilà on n'est pas sur une maladie ou
des cons vous touche globalement vous
allez avoir des complications gravissime
alors évidemment il ya toujours l'équipe
questions pratiques qu'on connaît tous
mais c'est bon de les répéter
quelles sont les précautions à prendre
c'est une précaution qu'on appelle les
barrières universelle qu'on devrait
prendre chaque année mais là encore plus
c'est que coronavirus s'élabore se laver
les mains prendre le réflexe de se laver
les mains régulièrement d'utiliser des
solutés hydro-alcooliques ces petits gel
qui permettent quand on n'a pas de point
d'eau de se désinfecter donc il faut le
faire encore plus souvent la deuxième
chose c'est de prendre des bons réflexes
ne pas aller tout c'est par exemple et
lé postillonner dans l'herbe est plutôt
utilisé sa manche et voyez vous allez
éternuer dans votre manche par exemple
utiliser des mouchoirs jetables pour
éviter d'avoir des réservoirs à microbes
et des réservoirs à virus et puis la
quatrième chose c'est quand on est soi
même malade c'est de porter un masque
mais là il faut complètement arrêtée
avec l'idée que le masque le masque
chirurgical a le petit masque bleu de
chirurgiens et ça ne protège pas du
virus on voit plein de gens se balader
dans la rue avec ce masque là les
pharmacies sont dévalisés ça ne sert à
rien ça protège quand soi-même on est
malade pour éviter de contaminer les
autres mais le masque ne filtre pas
assez les particules dans l'air et en
particulier les virus dont il faudrait
un masque de plus haute protection qu'on
a à l'hôpital par exemple pour éviter
d'être contaminée et l'autre fantasmes
qu'il faut complètement arrêté c'est la
discrimination sur les populations
asiatiques
voyez le mais la meilleure des preuves
c'est que parmi les cas qui sont
hospitalisés notamment le dernier c'est
pas du tout une personne asiatique donc
il faut arrêter avec ce bashing
systématique de dire attention je veux
pas mettre à côté d'un touriste chinois
où je parlais manger dans un restaurant
chinois
ça n'a aucun sens puisque ce n'est pas
la communauté chinoise qui véhiculent ça
ils se trouvent comme tous les virus de
la planète ils partent d'un endroit dans
le monde souvent c'est en asie pour des
raisons de saisonnalité tout simplement
et il se propage de toute façon sur la
planète
certains chercheurs on a lu peut-être
que c'est encore faux on veut nous le
dira et estime que cette épidémie
devrait connaître son pic d'ici une
semaine ou dix jours ça veut dire quoi
est ce qu'on est capable aujourd'hui de
dire bah combien de temps ça va durer
quelle importance ça va prendre
alors des modèles mathématiques qui
permettent effectivement de calculer
quand on sait qu'une personne va
contaminer par exemple trois ou quatre
personnes on est capable de faire la
cinétique de 2,7 de cette épidémie on
est capable aussi de voir sur la planète
comment elle se comment elles se
déplacent après les chercheurs estiment
le pic de l'épidémie mais c'est une
estimation ça peut se déplacer sapeurs-
flamber comme ça peut s'éteindre
d'ailleurs juste pour rassurer nos
téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices une
épidémie qui serait mortel le virus se
propage très très vite et qu'une
épidémie mortelle
vous mettez une ville sous cloche vous
voyez bien que vous aller éteindre
l'épidémie parce que malheureusement
vous allez avoir des milliers voire des
millions de morts
on en est je pense pas là parce que là
on aurait les informations donc on voit
bien qu'on est sur un modèle de
diffusion qui est plus un modèle
traditionnel une forte contagiosité mais
une gravité qui est notre invité pas si
élevé que ça ou en tout cas pas parce
qu'on imaginait au départ
donc c'est clair qu'il va falloir voir
la cinétique à la courbe avec le nombre
de cas qui va redescendre il peut y
avoir un rebond le voit très
classiquement et les épidémies de grippe
aussi mais en tout cas là le pic n'est
pas atteint ça c'est sûr et que on voit
bien que les cas augmentent et quand les
cas augmentent un peu partout sur la
planète
ça veut dire que progressivement toutes
les ondes s'allume et qu'on va arriver à
un stade de pandémie mais pandémie ne
veut pas dire mortalité élevée pandémie
ça veut tout simplement dire que le
monde entier il ya du virus qui circule
et ce en permanence on a des virus qui
circulent notamment le virus de la conte
merci gérald hiersac en tout cas pour
ces propos rassurants qui met les points
sur les i merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct